yo Josie WA has come a long way since
her Dance Moms days she had to learn
about the truth behind the life of the
rich and famous the hard way seriously
you won't believe the things this girl
has been through don't forget to hit
that notification bell to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out the dark side of
Jojo see was life of the rich and famous
Jojo Sela is pretty much everywhere you
turn if you have a child or a sibling
you probably have one of Dodos bows
lying somewhere around your house the
big personality with even bigger bows is
a well-known act among the YouTube TV
and music world she's pretty much one of
the busiest child stars you know and her
net worth allegedly stands at an
impressive eight million seriously eight
million for a teenager that's pretty
impressive isn't it but it's definitely
not all that glamorous as it seems and
from what it looks like it never was it
started with a harsh dance teacher
Jojo always wanted to be famous she was
pretty much a natural-born performer so
it only makes sense that she was chosen
for Abby's ultimate dance competition
the show was created by Abby Lee Miller
after her popularity as the dance
teacher on Dance Moms grew JoJo's stood
out from the crowd with her big bows and
big expressions when it came to dancing
although Jojo and her mom were often
criticized for having mob personalities
it all paid off in the end sometimes all
that matters is staying true to yourself
which is exactly what Jojo does both
were invited to join the official Dance
Moms team but that's when the trouble
began Abby Lee Miller's teaching
techniques are often criticized by the
viewing public from screaming and
shouting at the dancers to humiliating
them in front of others Abby didn't hold
back and she definitely used those same
techniques on Jojo who found herself
crying on camera plenty of times it
always seemed like Abby didn't like her
because JoJo's personality was way too
energetic but is it really a reason to
treat her the way she did and it wasn't
just her dance teacher her dance team
thought dodo is just a little too out
there and they weren't afraid to express
the
one of the most shocking moments of
Dance Moms came from a live Q&A the
casted with the fans a clip went viral
after some of the dancers started
mocking Jojo in front of hundreds of
Dance Moms fans they criticized her loud
personalities and even made some remarks
about how she won't shut up even if you
pour water on her
Jojo of course saw the clip after a fan
filmed the entire thing and posted it on
YouTube she actually ended up addressing
the entire situation on Dance Moms and
the girls
apologized after the news broke out that
Abby Lee is battling cancer
Jojo took the time to visit her in the
hospital and since her a lot of support
even though Jojo ended up unexpectedly
leaving the show she made it clear that
there was no bad blood between her and
Abby Lee but this was only a glimpse of
the harsh criticism Jojo would face
later
seriously JoJo's world is crazy and we
don't think we could live in it we all
know she has a big personality and she's
extremely confident and pretty much
everything she does but of course
because she puts herself out there and
doesn't hold back she sometimes it's a
lot of backlash and it isn't just
backlash sometimes it turns into
something even more terrifying Dance
Moms Fame sparked an obsession Jojo
actually had to deal with a serious
issue after and during her time on Dance
Moms
millions turned in to watch Dance Moms
and the show's average viewer ranges
from a teenager to an adult in their 50s
when Jojo was just 12 she had to deal
with ongoing harassment from an adult
man a person who goes by the name
Phoenix sundown he sent Jojo a bunch of
suspicious packages the packages looked
so weird dojo and her mom called the
police and the bomb squad had to arrive
to examine what was going on
that's quite extreme isn't it it turned
out that the man that was sending his
packages to dojo actually had a criminal
past getting weird messages is bad
enough but this is pretty scary we can't
even imagine how a 12 year old Jojo must
have felt and it was all because she
appeared on TV that's a pretty scary
thing for anyone to go through yet alone
a child her stalker ended up getting
sentenced to three years in prison after
was revealed that this wasn't the first
time he's done something like this
online bullying
jojo's standout personality made her a
popular target with online bullies they
picked on her in any way they could
and they became even louder when she
started her YouTube channel if you think
that Jojo is not aware of new comments
people read on social media you're wrong
she's actually completely aware and
she's addressed it more than once
in fact she's an advocate when it comes
to fighting against bullying from her
songs to activism Jojo refuses to let
the haters get their way and she
inspires her fans to do that too enjoy
your life be positive be happy and don't
let the haters get their way isn't that
the sweetest thing you've ever seen it
definitely helps to hear those words
from someone who's larger than life Jojo
was totally meant to become a star but
of course that comes with a lot of
consequences when Jojo appeared on a
British Morning Show called this morning
a lot of people weren't happy as you can
imagine she had a lot of energy
throughout the interview which ended up
earning the title of the most annoying
child star ever well at least according
to the viewers who really didn't have
nice things to say about her appearance
although she doesn't show it very often
Jojo does talk about how bullying
affects her through her songs one of her
most recent songs is a ballad called
only get better it was inspired by her
own YouTube video on bullying which
turned out to be one of the most watched
videos on her channel
Jojo said it's actually one of the
sadder videos because she doesn't tend
to get emotional
in fact she never gives the bullies any
recognition she just rises above it how
inspirational is that we just absolutely
love Jojo for being so positive and so
energetic Twitter meme speaking of her
energy Twitter can sometimes take JoJo's
jokes just a bit too far for example
JoJo's videos are always taken out of
context if you've never seen her YouTube
videos we really recommend watching at
least a few so you can get a full
understanding over who dodo really is
her vlogs are absolutely hilarious but
one thing people can't wrap their heads
around is her voice
Jojo communicates with her audience
extremely fast seriously it's so fast
she actually turned into a well-known
Twitter meme you could find hundreds of
jokes on the way Jojo talks and
of them really aren't that nice luckily
she just shrugs it off and pays no
attention to people she really does stay
true to her words doesn't she
Jojo don't let the haters get their way
Twitter beefs with celebrities being
famous sometimes means sharing the wrong
thing on social media and Jojo shared
something that made another viral meme
sensation quite angry in July 2018
Jojo shared a post written by one of her
adult fans who was praising her in the
same post the fan criticized Danielle
Drago Lee aka cashed me outside girl
Bianca named for her attitude since
Danielle and dojo are actually the same
age the person decided to compare the
two the fan said that she'd rather see
her daughter's see a role model than
someone like Jojo than Danielle burr
goalie of course fans immediately
thought Jojo was throwing shade at
Danielle and so did Danielle who
actually responded to Jojo in her own
way we won't repeat it but let's just
say it wasn't nice Jojo ended up
responding to Danielle's tweet and said
that the cash me outside girl is just
making her point even more yes as it
turned out she actually did shade
Danielle people took sides and the beef
actually made the gossip news it's
really clear that these two viral stars
don't really like each other but as of
October 2018 the two haven't said
anything else about one another we're
still waiting for that distract Danielle
what I just said
the dojo Beau's controversy we're
nowhere done yet it's quite surprising
that a teenager could experience so many
controversies in her life it's how you
know Jojo is just absolutely unique and
definitely has the star quality people
totally pay attention when it comes to
her whether it's good or bad but the UK
actually had quite a lot of problems
when it came to one thing
Jojo bows it's not a secret that Jojo
loves her bows and she wears them all
the time of course she trademarked it
and made sure every kid around the globe
can buy one of her over the top Jojo
bows and seriously her bows are pretty
popular among the school crowd there in
fact so popular kids who don't wear bows
got bullied by the
that do the popularity of the bows
allegedly sparked quite a competition
among those wearing them some were even
making fun of other kids if they thought
their Jojo bows weren't real and parents
were absolutely furious
eventually schools in the UK started
banning the bows and stated that they
don't really comply with the typical
school uniform fake memes becoming a
real meme is one thing we've seen that
with Danielle brew goalie as she gains
her title of cache me outside girl and
took over the Internet's it was her
appearance on dr. Phil that turns her
into a viral internet sensation but not
all memes are exactly positive Twitter
often shows its dark side when it comes
to going too far by trying to make
things funny do you remember the Milly
Bobby Brown controversy that ended up in
Milly deleting her social media well in
August 2018
Jojo went through exactly the same thing
people turned her into an anti-gay meme
after dodo tweeted a picture of herself
with a caption saying I want to become a
mean of course Twitter took it way too
seriously and it just didn't go down
well people started posting white
supremacy memes and putting fake quotes
and fake snapchat captions on her photos
she didn't end up deleting her social
media but we have a feeling she realized
herself just how much of a bad idea this
was we just hope she didn't take the
time to read every meme under her tweet
let's be honest she really doesn't need
to see that right is Jojo Cu a fake with
the rise of youtubers and celebrities
who are just putting on a persona it's
no wonder some people questioned whether
or not Jojo is actually real if you've
ever met her you probably already know
that Jojo is 100% real after all it's
her big personality that got her on
Dance Moms
and turned her into a huge Nickelodeon
star she confirmed that she doesn't
pretend or put on a show for the camera
that's just how Jojo is in real life
speaking of real life the internet went
crazy after they found out Jojo is
actually scarily tall she might be just
a teenager but Jojo actually confirmed
herself that she's five nine
that's almost 180 centimeters for those
of you on the metric system
she's probably taller than some of your
favorite celebrities in fact she's
pretty much the same height as Abby Lee
Miller how crazy is that not only is
this girl rising above her haters in a
metaphorical way she's also doing it
IRL you go Jojo with the bow bow what do
you think of Jojo co-come debate in the
comments don't forget
Jojo is totally against online bullying
and you should be too so make sure you
say something nice about at least to one
of the people in the comment section and
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
see you next time